okay there's this Dutch historian named
Rutger Bregman who sort of went viral
when he went to Davos a few weeks ago
and said hey the problem is tax
avoidance none of you people here are
talking about it corporations
represented at Davos don't want to talk
about it rich people who are speaking at
Davos don't want to talk about it and
tax avoidance and tax rates are what we
need to be talking about a very
interesting clip that he participated in
from Davos this got Tucker Carlson from
Fox News interested in Rutger Bregman
and in fact Rutger Bregman recorded an
interview on Tucker Carlson's program
last week but the interview was never
aired we now have leaked video from the
control room of this interview again the
interview never aired on Fox News Rutger
Bregman absolutely destroys Tucker
Carlson completely embarrasses and
triggers him to the point where Tucker
Carlson starts hurling expletives
insults and obscenities at Rutger
Bregman and this ran completely counter
to the character that Tucker Carlson is
known for and wants to portray which is
that of being completely in control at
all times being a master debater all of
that different stuff it went south
Tucker clearly didn't know how to handle
the obvious truths that Bregman was
confronting him with I'm not gonna play
all of it but let's check out a few
pieces of this interview excuse me of
this interview here is where Bregman
starts going in on Fox News during his
interview with Tucker Carlson no one's
saying that I devote just as no one
saying it on Fox News right and I think
the explanation for that is quite simple
is that most of the people in Davos but
also here on this channel have been
bought by the billionaire class you know
you're not meant to say these things so
I just went there and I thought you know
what I'm just gonna say it just as I'm
saying it right here on this channel for
years even though the vast majority of
Americans is in favor of it okay so you
can already see that Tucker Carlson sort
of unsure about how to handle what's
going on here so he starts to try to
divert he says I don't know how much box
you've watched but Bregman goes back to
this main point time and time again and
in this next clip you'll notice Tucker
starting to get more and more annoyed
with them no I mean it doesn't work that
directly but I mean you've been part of
the Cato Institute right you're you've
been a senior fellow there for years
you've been you've been taken their
dirty money they're funded by Koch
billionaires you know well it works by
you taking their dirty money it's as
easy as that
I mean you are a millionaire funded by
billionaires that's what you are and I'm
glad you now finally doomed the bent leg
and you know of people like Bernie
Sanders and AFC but you're not you're
not part of the solution mr. and mr.
Colson you're part of the problem
actually so later on Tucker continues to
get more and more annoyed tells Bregman
you haven't even watched Fox News
because it's not on in Europe and of
course Bregman just points out that the
internet exists it's true right it's
true right that all the all the anchors
all the anchors on Fox
they're all millionaires how is this
possible well it's very easy you're just
gonna talking about certain things it
doesn't play where you are
well have you heard of the Internet I
can watch things whatever I want I have
actually so the argument becomes over
whether Rutger Bregman is even able to
watch Fox News from Europe and then
here's the sort of last piece of this
where Tucker just completely loses it
you're all like oh I'm against a
globalist to lead blah blah blah it's
not very convincing to be honest
absolutely great stuff never aired only
when it leaked did Tucker Carlson have
to give some kind of an explanation
which he did last night on Fox News he
put out a video claiming to assert why
they didn't air it as if we needed an
explanation here's what Tucker claims
are the reasons this never got broadcast
he was in Europe at the time so we taped
the segment in case we need to fix the
delay in the Edit booth we do that a lot
things went fine for the first few
minutes and then Bregman launched into
an attack on Fox News it's not clear
that Bregman has ever seen Fox but he
wanted to make his point fine but then
he claimed that my corporate masters
tell me what to say on this show and
that was too much
whatever my faults are those of this
channel nobody in management has ever
told us what positions to take on the
air never not one time we have total
freedom here and we're grateful for that
I've hosted shows on both the other
cable channels so I know firsthand how
rare that freedom is this show thanks to
Fox we get to say exactly what we think
is true for better or worse but there
was no convincing Rutger Bregman of that
he knew what he knew so I did what I try
hard never to do on this show and I was
rude I called him a [ __ ] and then I
modified that word with a vulgar vulgar
anglo-saxon term that is also
intelligible in Dutch my defense I would
say that that was entirely accurate but
you're not allowed to use that word on
television so once I'd said it out loud
there was no airing the segment these
explanations make absolutely no sense
so first Tucker says well Bregman was
rude and he said things that weren't
true
so we canceled
the segment well wrong people being rude
to Tucker is sort of like how his show
gets ratings and people being rude to
each other and yelling and and making
claims like this it makes for great TV
normally as long as Carlson feels like
he's still in control and he would just
call the guy out as rude if he hadn't
lost control of the segment then he says
well I swore on camera and that makes
the segment not usable well you could
have removed that one piece like you
said you weren't doing it live so that
you would have the opportunity to edit
it if possible
you also could just bleep the word the
way that we did in the version that we
aired so the idea that the entire
segment was no longer usable because he
dropped an f-bomb is also not believable
and then he says we didn't air it
because Bregman said things that weren't
true like for example that my bosses
tell me what to say which is again not a
reason not to air the segment just tell
him why he's wrong people have gone on
the Tucker Carlson program before and
asserted things Tucker doesn't believe
to be true
he doesn't cancel the segment when that
happens so this is just not how it works
and there's a couple really important
things I want to mention here number one
there are some leftists who including my
friend Jen Kyogre with peace and love
who who tweeted that he thinks that
Tucker should be praised for actually
talking about tax avoidance I don't
agree that Tucker deserves praise for
this segment he didn't bring Rutger
Bregman on to actually have a discussion
about raising tax rates and stopping tax
avoidance
he brought Rutger Bregman on to
criticize Jeff Bezos and specific left
associated billionaires and the
so-called elites who go to Davos and
quote limousine liberals and to make
this a partisan attack on supposedly
hypocritical leftists who pay low taxes
and have a bunch of money but call for
high taxes but don't actually pay for
them this was not a good-faith effort to
actually expose the problems with the
tax code across the world and
particularly in the United States that
allow people like Tucker to pay really
low rates if he had done it in good
faith it would have been one thing but
he didn't and then lastly the accusation
that Rutger Bregman levies on Tucker as
a millionaire control
by billionaires on fox news that's
actually not unique to fox news if you
understand how corporate media works you
could make that argument about most of
the people on CNN you could make that
argument about most of the people on
MSNBC although yes on MSNBC because of
their editorial perspective you do see
more people talking about why
economically it would be better to have
higher taxes you're still dealing with
corporate structures where it's
billionaires controlling millionaires
and even if they don't tell them what to
say this is the old Aarti defense no one
from Russia tells me what to say they
don't tell me to say pro-russia stuff
you are hired because they know what
you're going to say and what you're
going to say is useful to them that's
not actually how it works so overall we
know why it didn't get aired because
Tucker got embarrassed it wasn't a
good-faith attempt to talk about
taxation and good for Rutger Bregman
although I agree he was doing a lot of
tucking over talking over a Tucker and
interrupting him and if there's any
criticism it would be that he shouldn't
have done that because it makes you sort
of seem overtly adversarial but I
understand why he did it and he did a
really really good job let me know what
you think about this segment I'm on
Twitter at D Pakman the show is on
Twitter at David Pakman show